salve ragazzi avete questo nuovissimo
video io sono parecchio ci siamo su
roche boero introdurvi allo sponsor di
tutela anche l'attività più sicura che
lo abbiamo fatto e adesso capirete il
perché come molti di voi sapranno
ragazzi pc gamer sono molto molto molto
attaccati da minacce virus robe del
genere perché perché per paura di far
calare le prestazioni quando tu sei il
videogiocatore magari non installi
antivirus robe del genere
quindi il tuo account di gaming suo
computer da gaming potrebbe essere regno
di informazioni facilmente
intercettabili da malintenzionati anche
cose personali privacy indirizzi tutte
queste cose qua ci viene in soccorso il
mitico norton che è un dio scandinavo ma
è l'anti virus number one anche per i pc
gamer come volete vedere e poco invasivo
e anche molto facile vedere anche la
schermata cioè la capisco io che non
capisco una mazza
innanzitutto ti protegge dalle minacce
in tempo reale con la scansione rapida
che ho già fatto 62 volte poi ci sono un
sacco di roba tipo la protezione
internet i backup le prestazioni
ovviamente che sono assolutamente
preservate dopodiché ragazzi potete
utilizzare anche il bbm per una
navigazione molto più sicura visto che
chiunque ne avrebbe bisogno abbiamo 50
gigabyte di backup per il vostro
computer
abbiamo anche il password manager per i
magari tribunale per il magazine e
immagazzinare una parola difficile tutte
le password in modo sicuro abbiamo anche
la safe cam per intervenire su eventuali
intrusioni nella nostra webcam quindi
così può più efficace di così è per il
pc meglio ragazzi c'erano dalle tasche
mistero che viene rilevata e c'è anche
l'ottimizzazione le notifiche che
vengono visualizzate solo se il pc è
sotto attacco su compì situazioni
importanti infine possiamo proteggere
come vedete qua fino a tre dispositivi e
io adesso potete solo questo ma mi
accingo a proteggere tutti anche il
frigo allora ragazzi c'è stata la season
3 e nelle partite di piazzamento della
season 3 è successo l'impossibile
giampiero ha fatto un best of dei
momenti con un finale che merita l'oscar
veramente ragazzi godetevi questo video
la precisazione che faccio è che c'è la
grafica un po più bassa del solito
perché è una live spezzettata quindi per
quello vedete un po peggio del solito
solo per questo motivo qua guardatevi il
video ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta
lo spoiler ama tanto avete detto nel
titolo quindi chi se ne frega buona
visione di vincere almeno nove partite
per la cartigli amante 9 ma chi se ne
frega ce nel senso tanto non importa
arrivare subito la francia rito
[Musica]
guarda guarda guarda anche di questi
vermi
belli
riuscito a segnare yes yes man che barba
mia
meno male che lui arrivato dov'è non è
gol lo stesso niente una società farina
che lo scavetto per cucchiaio tensione
tra la puntata che il sindaco ha fatto
un culo quadro 414 punti 2 gol
quattro di questi erano champion
regalerà un champion
e allora allora ce la puoi fare trainer
mai non so non sono sicuro non abbiamo
una certa dovremmo chiedere sviluppatori
adesso c è il bravo che il gioco ti ha
messo contro i 100 perché tu hai un mmr
molto alto come ti mette contro i cenni
e ho capito però a me va bene basta
champions è però non faccio tutti gol
magari ci sta anche che non mi ci
mettano a bere un po storto si sta però
potevo anche sfruttare meglio location e
io ho fatto paura che questi carichi no
dove sei assi amica ma vedi che
comunicare non è importante non ragazzo
scrive io sono brogi e greco tipologia
di sceglierò bronzo lo sono ancora ma
dipende anche contro chi mi mette perché
se ne vinci no io ho vinte 9 93 95
dipende punto che insieme li mette
contro i platinum vinco avvenuto dieci
però non vale niente cioè vale cioè
diamanti dicono quasi tutti i vostri
platino per forza meno che non sia la
partita sfortunatissima quindi pene
contro chi dimette non quante ne vincete
solo capito e quello che sto dice se mi
mette contro i 100 come le vinco 10 dei
pedoni non perdere
popolazioni nostra partita gli operai un
rank a non lo so questo non mai a nolo
saltato non certo abbassato angola tina
giusto però bellissimo come si ripiglia
mio compagno questo passaggio bravissimo
bravo o bravo che è bell azione bel
passaggio è bel gol così si gioca mai
dai vinciamola questa per favore di
charly gaul e bravo bravo il compagno
bravo bravo bravissimo ha fatto un bel
controlli ma questo deve essere forte si
vedono ma si vede che con questo giocare
con gente ma infatti io vorrei giocare
così pensa se avessi il mio set up e
band oltre a roma mentre robbie causare
man show guarda non è vero ma cosa tolto
e non andavano volta del blues brother e
tua sei da solo però depp facevo io
voglio non a cagher 44 tensione il sito
6 giocando veramente gravità cento
veramente bravi
e che gol ragazzi bellissimo viventi pro
vasto gol non l'ha toccata non l'ha
toccata e quello non se l'aspettava
nell'altro casse e quindi entrata casa
bellissimo lo del bravo mamma mia mamma
mia tutti i palloni prendono bravissimi
piacere giocare così tutti tutti tutto
giusto tutto quello che guardo che
voglio che succeda succede ma perché ho
tirato così eccola tutti da una bella
piega prima offerta a prenderla
rimbalzo no meno male che anche lui era
difficile no ma non maniera veramente
difficili dove la toglierla non so come
ho fatto a toglierla questi notturno
sono importa questa qua e rischioso 8
bravo salute motivo fosse semi a ridurre
bella li attenzione però deve ritirare
bravissimo bravissimo bravissimo signor
no attraversa perché i ragazzi
regalatevi un gol adesso che vi serve
brother dove vai se vinco vincerla
questa per forza pirati
perché poi e 55 dovrebbero anche armi
per forza matematicamente ii e comunque
tipo artista in vantaggio mi dovrebbero
mancare per forzare i prof
poi perché abbiamo 5 vittorie 5
sconfitte al massimo però devo vincerla
non pensiamo a questo senso giocarla del
sospettato ecco porca vacca quello dal
muro esamina cms stavo in poi è vero non
potevo fare raffronti road allison
questo attirato da lì è stato bravissimo
ho saltato lo stesso
mamma mia madre che la gente
[Musica]